this is in some ways an homage I think
that you have certainly omage is here
too John Ford and some of the Great's
you know you're standing in the shadows
of some of those great directors who
have made these yeah it's always tough
when you make a film in a genre like the
Western or even the gangster genre which
some of the best films ever made reside
so immediately you're going to be
compared to those films but I didn't the
film doesn't flinch from America's dark
and unforgiveable past of attempted
genocide towards our indigenous people
but it also is I think speaking to some
of the modern concerns that we have this
very vast racial and cultural divide
that seems to be getting wider by the
day so I wanted to pay homage to to Ford
some of the psychological westerns of
Anthony Mann but also make it feel very
very contemporary now Christian you
worked with Scott before out of the
furnace and this is your second teaming
with him is it where what was it about
this character Blocher he's a very
interesting complex guy in this movie
what was it about that that appealed to
you when you saw this grip well one of
the things that really appealed was the
pacing of looking at you know how people
would have behaved at that time the you
know the fact you don't go racing your
horse you're walking it and then there's
sudden the violence is sudden and
extreme when it does happen and then
goes again of this of this solitary
nature of a man who's been out in this
for behringer for years and years and
years and what I liked watching Ken
Burns's Civil War documentary thinking
that that was you know how blocker would
have grown up and I kind of sort of
imagined even though they were meant to
be older many you know 12 13 14 year
olds of fighting in the Civil War and so
I pictured him kind of being in the
hornet's nest at Shiloh and that's kind
of really been his entire life there's
been firing and he's a dutiful soldier
he does exactly what he is he's meant to
do I know that with Scott he tells his
stories beautifully
is and this is a absolutes whole
compliment kind of an invisible director
like he doesn't want to put his own sort
of character stamp it onto the film he
just wants to kind of let it be seen and
I love that and really really love
working with him he gets extraordinary
performances from actors because he lets
them you know be comfortable and come at
it with their strengths and and for me I
found it really fascinating in terms of
the learned hatred that the blocker had
to you know a choir and a crew to do
what he did the personal tragedies of
his brothers in arms who he had seen
murdered and often butchered brutally as
compared to the larger atrocity of the
of the genocide and and knowing that
although Blocher has had to create this
fierce hatred of yellow hawk he knows
full well he's a smart man he knows full
well that if he was in yellow hawk shoes
he would behave exactly the same way and
I see it as very much an indictment of
politicians that you know a blocker is
is is doing what he has been instructed
to do and does it extraordinarily well
and then suddenly the whims of DC change
and his his attitude is no longer the
correct one and suddenly you know he's
threatened with the court-martialing and
everything and seeing these men who
really have to live day to day life and
death and witnessing that compared to
the safety of the politicians in
Washington who then he struck these men
and threatened them and just how
disgusting that that attitude is and
that correlates obviously very much to
what was going on today and and and
since since 1892 and then long before as
well this role I've seen you in so many
movies and so many great roles dances
with what on and on and on in your
career well how does this one fit into
that to this particular store
and what it's saying for today's
audiences what did you respond to well I
think it just went a little bit further
than perhaps the ones that I've done
before you know and that's what always
is what invites me to do a part is or
it's a challenge to play someone who's
actually dying you know over a long
period of time what does it feel like to
know that you only have a certain number
of days to live and it's not anything
that I could recall from my own life to
bring to the screen at that time nothing
ever other than having watched maybe
another person slowly die but that's the
only reference I had to the whole thing
and well where I went with it was to you
know concentrate on the lack or loss of
hope of a future what does one do at the
end of one's life but yeah that that's
that was the other part of the whole
experience was that aspect of it Cory
Anka you have worked with Christian
before in the new world right well yes
all three of you this is a big reunion
here yeah yes and this role meant a lot
to you too you've worked in a lot up
with a lot outside you're an activist in
indigenous issues and things and so can
you talk about it from that point of
view for you what it means to be in this
movie and what you do in your own life
as well when I was a little girl it was
actually always a dream of mine to do a
Western there was something so romantic
and so beautiful about it and I always
longed to live back in the day when you
traveled like a like nomads on horseback
and were one with nature and that going
back to the the the simplicity and the
basics of life and so when I first read
the script I
just say like yay this is one that I can
you know check off my bucket list of of
a film that I would love to be a part of
and you know from I guess the activist
standpoint of you you know I really feel
like Hollywood is moving in the
direction of being fine finally becoming
more inclusive and I think it's so
important and I really really respected
and appreciated Scott and Christians
advocacy for really really making sure
that you know there were the proper
representatives of the Xiuying community
on set every single day and one thing
that you know really struck me because I
don't know many directors or anyone in
Hollywood that would actually take the
time to do something like this pretty
much every single day Scott and everyone
the whole crew we'd gather around in a
circle and chief Phillip would do a
prayer before we would begin the day of
filming and you know it just set the
tone and it was just so wonderful and
very inspiring and you know I feel as
filmmakers and artists it's our
responsibility to continuously break
down those barriers and push forward
with the films that we make because we
have this amazing platform to help
amplify those voices that are seldom
heard and bring to life important
stories and you know I think this film
was such a great step in the in the
right direction and I really hope I
really hope that it continues to go down
this road Tom you came off movies like
whiplash and la-la-land what was it like
you know editing a Western and working
with Scott it was the same as lala land
now I yeah I'm going I went from one old
extinct Hollywood genre to another
extinct Hollywood and I loved it yeah no
Scott Scott and I worked together I was
an assistant editor on Crazy Heart which
was Scott's first film and we got to
know one another and and I feel very
lucky that our stars got to a line and
that that I got a call from Scott to do
this picture we kind of got to get the
band back together so to speak you know
it's interesting this is the first film
I've edited where I've worked on as an
assistant of work for many years on a
lot of films that have had violence and
death and man this is the first one I've
really cut that's had a lot of darkness
in it and you know but the first thing
that Scott told me was he said you know
this is not going to be your daddy's
Western it's the way he put it to me and
what he meant by that was that he wanted
this film to be more psychological more
a psychological portrait rather than a
presentational one so in terms of the
cutting you know Scott really encouraged
me to create a measured pace a patient
pace with the landscapes and the vistas
and encouraged me to do these long
dissolves and superimpositions and and
the hope was that that would not only
show you the great Geographic distances
that these characters travel but it
would also touch on the the emotional
distance that they traveled and you know
it would it would really heighten where
they started and the place of
enlightenment and and added empathy that
they got to in their destination so you
know as an editor it all it always
starts with the characters for me and
actually that's where it kind of ends as
well I mean for these action scenes
whether you know whether it's a drum
solo or you know a musical number or you
know the end of hostiles if you don't
understand where the characters are at
or or what their motivations are or you
don't understand what they're going
through emotionally then
you don't really have a scene as my
opinion so anyways that was again psych
more psychological and little
psychological first and Western second
in a way thank you all for coming out
here guys